un
[Musique]
jour je quitterais tous
un jour je partirai seul
sans peine et pour presque rien
pour sauf le de jeunesse
un jour je quitterais tout
bord un instant de tendresse
[Musique]
je tiendrai tous mes biens
ma maison mes amis
mes chiens
adieu l'heure incertaine du petit matin
la liberté au bout du chemin
dans l'aura
je souffre d'un sapin
bonjour l'instant qui sou
ou tout de la vie les traceux timmins
sous la pluie
il à venir sans vis à vis
[Musique]
un jour je quitterais tout
oh
un jour je disparaîtrai
mon poignet le soleil
pour que
heures de sommeil
un jour je quitterais tout
les bruits qui vous rende fou
les nuits blanche l'alcool flatteur
les chaînons
en forme de coeur
adieu
mais bizet du petit matin les forêts
lisanti lointain il frémur à portée de
la main
[Musique]
bonjour une vie nouvelle une vie centre
ans est passé en forme de coeur a peur
un avenir qui m'ont
un jour je disparaîtrai
tous ceux qui ont brûlé mana
tous
kim on tirait des là
je quitte
tous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]